hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an episode from the Thai
mystery thriller Anthology series girl
from nowhere called Liberation spoilers
ahead watch out ants take care
pentana with taya's school from Bangkok
is notorious for being the strictest
School in the country it is rumored that
even the most notorious of students are
straightened out by the time they
graduate from here in total the school
has 427 rules that have to be followed
on a regular basis these rules are so
vast that an entire book has been
dedicated to them anyone found
disobeying them even if it's by mistake
is sentenced to harsh punishment like
isolation bodily harm and even death
because of this the students always live
in fear they have no opinions look
lifeless and act like puppets on the
other hand the teachers are heartless
and cruel all they want to do is hurt
the students hence the school has lost
its charm and everything appears in
black and white bringing anything
colorful inside the premises is in
offense except the principal who for
some reason wears a bright pink suit at
the start of the show a new student
named Nano arrives at Pantano attire
school she is a cheerful girl who likes
to have fun but as soon as she enters
through the gay everything around her
turns black and white after she reaches
Class A teacher asks her to introduce
herself Nano complies and greets her new
friends but they just reply with a vague
smile soon the class begins and Nano
gets seated near a shy-looking girl she
tries to initiate a conversation but to
no avail later as she is unpacking her
stuff Nano accidentally drops her
lipstick which is dark red in color this
pierces through the black and white
environment and all of her classmates
notice it fortunately the teacher is
distracted and before she can catch wind
of it the shy-looking girl picks it up
Nano thanks her and quickly hides it
inside her bag however just a few
moments later the discipline in charge
of the school Lisa shows up with her
minions she is revealed to be the
cruelest teacher around some students
are so terrified of her on sight that
they immediately wet their pants that's
not pee today Lisa has come to conduct a
random bag search when it's Nano's turn
she tries her best to explain that going
through others personal belongings is an
invasion of privacy however Lisa
forcefully snatches her bag and goes
through it the entire class holds their
breath expecting the lipstick to be
found any time now but to their surprise
it's not there the clever Nano has
somehow concealed it somewhere else and
everyone called me crazy for putting
things up my butt she smirks menacingly
as Lisa departs with her minions shortly
after Nana starts showing her true self
she is actually a rebel whose sole
purpose is to change the customs and
rules of pantanawataya's school she
doesn't care about studying or making
friends all she wants is to punish the
teachers and make them pay for their
crimes for the first step she brings out
her lipstick and puts it on in front of
the entire class everyone is stunned to
see a rule being defied like this in the
next scene Nano is with the shy girl at
the cafeteria the latter has finally
started opening up but nonetheless she
advises Nano to be careful with her
Antics she gives examples of two
students who are sent to the scary
repentance room for breaking the rules
it is already already been three days
but the students are yet to be released
surprisingly even after hearing this
Nano is not bothered even in the
slightest instead she starts laughing
like a maniac this catches the attention
of Lisa who also happens to be around
when she also notices Nano's colored
lips she immediately wipes it off and
takes away her lipstick as a form of
punishment Nano is ordered to memorize
all of the 427 rules from the book while
standing in the scorching heat however
our Rebel girl is not going to be
intimidated so easily as the Minions
look on Nano starts laughing at each and
every rule inside the book this draws
the attention of several students and
even some teachers Lisa also arrives and
right in front of her eyes Nano brings
out a lighter and burns the book down
everyone calls her crazy but Nano simply
says there's no rule that says you can't
burn the book regardless she is dragged
to the repentance room where two
speakers are constantly blasting the 437
rules this is enough to make anyone go
into but Nano seems to be undeterred she
yawns and laughs like it's a normal day
for her the following day Nano is
already back in her class this time she
is wearing a bright green ribbon as a
sign of Defiance the classmates are
shocked to see her back so early and
Nano reveals that she has memorized all
of the rules she also asserts that the
repentance room was not so scary after
all in fact if all the students broke
the rules they could have a big party
there the conversation slowly starts to
interest her classmates but just then
Lisa arrives even she is shocked to see
Nano out as she doesn't remember
releasing her Lisa warns the girl to
abide by the rules but the latter
bluntly says this school sucks having
had enough Lisa once again takes Nano to
the repentance room but this time for an
even more severe punishment once they
arrive Lisa flashes extremely powerful
lights into the poor girl's eyes and
makes her utter the 427 rules this goes
on for the entire day back in the
evening Nana was once again back to her
classroom this time she has dyed her
hair completely purple all the other
students also appear to be on her side
now slowly but steadily Nano is
succeeding in her mission that she came
here for as expected Lisa takes her to
the repentance room again there she asks
Nana what she wants the purple-haired
girl laughs for a while and then asserts
that she wants the entire system to be
changed all the rules that have been
constricting the students of their
freedom have to be abolished hearing all
of this Lisa loses her cool as the
ultimate punishment she pulls out Nano's
tongue with a plier however despite the
immense pain Nano can't stop laughing
later as Lisa is in her office
reminiscing about her day a new student
named Yuri approaches her she introduces
herself and reveals that she knows Nano
very well as they both studied in the
same school previously Yuri then
requests to be made the head inspector
and she is the only one who can help
keep Nano under check Lisa doesn't
believe her so Yuri brings out her phone
and shows a group chat of all the
students who are planning an uprising
she reveals that she used a fake
identity to track what the student are
up to impressed Lisa finally agrees to
make Yuri the head inspector of the
school in the next scene all the
rebellious students from the group chat
are punished they are made to kneel down
the whole night as the days pass by Yuri
starts winning over Lisa's trust and
gains access to her office one day she
sneaks inside the office and goes
through some confidential documents it's
clear that Yuri is also up to something
elsewhere Nano is once again back to her
class she can even speak despite having
her tongue taken out a few days ago when
she reaches her desk she finds an
envelope waiting for her it is wrapped
in a red ribbon with the words top
secret written on it Nano Just Smiles as
she excitedly opens the envelope the
scene then cuts to a few hours later
where Nano is heading somewhere with a
bunch of posters on the way she comes
across her old Nemesis Yuri who is
wearing a similar ribbon to the one that
she has wrapped around the envelope this
reveals that she was the sender Nano
appears to be in a hurry so she simply
tells Yuri to get out of her way before
leaving after a while she reaches the
top floor and prepares to paste a few
posters that but right then Lisa arrives
at the scene and stops her she inquires
what's in those posters and Nano with a
smirk on her face explains that it has
all the information about the school's
corruption every year the government and
several other organizations donate
millions of dollars to the school hoping
they can improve their facilities
however not even five percent of those
funds are even used the school continues
to be as dirty as ever the rooms are
dilapidated and the food tastes like
garbage it is evident that all the
teachers are keeping the money for
themselves hearing all this Lisa loses
her cool and attempts to snatch away the
posters Nano doesn't let go and hence
the two get into a minor tussle
surprisingly Yuri is recording all of
this from a corner after a while she
approaches the two and suddenly pushes
Nano down from the balcony killing her
instantly the entire school is
traumatized by the manner in which Nano
has been killed meanwhile Yuri throws
all the posters down and lets the
students know about how corrupt their
teachers actually are but she also sends
the video she recorded earlier to the
group chat hence making it seem as if
Lisa was responsible for Nana's death
the plan worked and as soon as the
students go through the video and the
posters they become enraged in a matter
of seconds they turn into animals and
start chasing after all the teachers of
pantana wataya's school Lisa is also
caught and just like the other teachers
she is bound and beat up later all the
teachers are brought to the main hall
Yuri who is now acting as the voice of
the students steps forward and announces
that the rules will change for years the
students have been suppressed and
tormented but now it will be the other
way around the teachers will have to
play by their rules and if someone does
not obey they will be punished inside
the repentance room saying this she
tells all the teachers to write down
their confessions on a piece of paper
While most of them oblige the evil Lisa
merely laughs and refuses to write
anything down this enrages some of the
students so she puts her in a Chokehold
to teach her a lesson unfortunately In
the Heat of the Moment he doesn't
realize that Lisa has actually stopped
breathing after all the students find
out that the boys killed their teacher
they suddenly turn on him some say that
he should be sent to the repentance room
while others demand his execution
fortunately the principle arrives in the
neck of time with a gun in his hand he
threatens everyone to stand down and
then frees the captive teachers
following this the principal gives the
students a choice if they confess to
their crimes and promise to never be
disobedient again he will forgive their
mistakes even the murder of Lisa as soon
as he says this many cowardly students
start pleading forgiveness but some of
them remain silent one of them is Yuri
after a while the principal gathers
these rebellious students at one place
to punish them at first he summons Yuri
as she was the one who initiated all of
this he then brings out a sharp knife
and prepares to execute her but right
then surprisingly a bloodied Nano
appears she is miraculously come back
from the dead then three other versions
of her show up too one has her tongue
cut out one is wearing a green ribbon
and the final one is the Nano who had
just arrived at the school it turns out
that every time Nano is punished a new
version of her replaced her older self
this explains why she was always back in
her class despite being locked inside
the repentance room the four Nanos
immediately lock all the doors trapping
the terrorized teachers then the version
of Nana who had just died recently
confronts the principle and threatens
him to put the gun down the latter says
no and prepares to pull the trigger on
her but right then all the students
bring out their most lethal weapons
their smartphones they go live and
record their evil principle who is ready
to kill his students in the name of
discipline this finally scares the big
fat principle and he drops the gun as
soon as he does so the students swarm
him and take him down taking advantage
of the commotion the cunning Yuri tries
to get away but Nano stops her in this
way the entire administration of pontana
wataya school is brought to their knees
now the students don't have to live in
the fear of being punished they can be
carefree and mischievous like normal
high school students should in the last
scene Nano locks her Nemesis Yuri in the
repentance room along with all the
teachers then with her objective now
completed she departs the school forever
I guess we're just never going to answer
the whole clone thing what happened
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching